you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up
another oil and gas company post record
profits as the cost of living rises what
should they be spending their money on
which part of the world is leading the
way in corporate climate action the
answers might surprise you
and the young inventors using tech to
come up with their planet saving
solutions
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world hear from
the people being hardest hit by those
changes and reports on the race for
solutions so we know that shell has
reported record profits in the first
three months of the year managing to
capitalize on the current volatility in
the world's energy markets they made
over nine billion dollars that's more
than seven million pounds and the huge
profits reported by both bp and shell
this week have led to renewal calls for
a windfall tax ian king is our business
presenter
the largest company in the ftse 100 has
today reported its best quarterly
results in 14 years the company reported
profits during the first three months of
this year of 9.1 billion us dollars that
compared with 6.4 billion us dollars for
the final three months of 2021 and was
up from 3.2 billion dollars for the same
three months last year now that of
course is partly down to higher oil and
gas prices but it also reflects in
particular a stronger performance in
liquefied natural gas and that is a
market in which shell is the world's
leading trader and obviously as a lot of
countries particularly in europe have
sought to wean themselves off russian
gas or demand for lng has just grown
because that is one of the products with
which countries are seeking to
substitute their dependence on russian
gas as shell has benefited from that its
trading division has also done
particularly well during the quarter
that is not something that is
automatically a result of higher oil and
gas prices it's very easy to lose money
in that particular trading activity if
you get things wrong so cho has done
particularly well on that front as well
now this is have inevitably led to some
calls for a full tax on oil and gas
companies as did bps strong results
earlier this week now there's something
of a row being going on in cabinet over
this the chancellor rishi sunak has made
clear that he would like to see oil and
gas companies recycling more of those
profits into the uk if they are to see
off the threat of a win full tax now bp
did that earlier this week they
announced that between now and the end
of the decade it will be investing some
18 billion pounds here in the uk now
shell has not gone into details today
about how much it will be investing in
the uk but in total it's expecting to
invest between 20 and 25 billion pounds
in the country between now and the end
of the decade much of that according to
ben van burden the chief executive will
be in renewables products
energy companies are in the spotlight
this week but the private sector more
broadly has a huge role to play in
helping the world hit its climate
targets now just a reminder these are
the big numbers that we're playing with
now and to slow climate change we need
to stop this number the temperature from
going up and to do that we need to make
sure that carbon emissions
cut or at least balanced out by 2050.
now esg that's environmental social and
governance is well it's a big part of
what businesses do the world over it's
what they do beyond purely seeking
profit and climate action is a big part
of that and one organization esg book
has collated emissions data from the
hundred biggest companies in each region
of the world and it's come up with some
surprising numbers um so let's just take
a look at this chart now and you can see
the companies in the asia pacific region
and the middle east have uh made
virtually no dent in their emissions at
all in the past seven years north
america and europe have done well a
little better but still way off the
targets they need uh to be aiming for
but interestingly companies in
sub-saharan africa and even more so
latin america well they're leading the
way and joining me now is to explain a
little bit more is todd bridges global
head of esg researcher albert wesk who
helped collate the data uh tom
thank you very much for joining us and
it's really interesting isn't it that
the line about the sub-saharan countries
and uh latin america are leading the way
could you explain to us why that's
happening
yeah perfect and it's a pleasure to chat
with you um yeah this research is based
on a series of multiple years of data
acquisition by esg book on scope one and
two data
for hundreds of companies across region
and what we have found is that over a
time period as you just introduced
2015 to 2020
the scope 1 2 data
node
suggests that companies by region are
reacting differently
and in particular
south africa
as a nation we have a number of data
points within that region and companies
in particular
that are showing progress right we're
looking at over time about a 20
reduction on average
for those companies within the sample
um same thing in latin tam we have
approximately 35 to 40 reduction again
with the companies reported
it's very important to
use these research and these studies to
make potential conclusions but for us
you know it's mission critical that we
as a as a global community of investors
uh and corporations speak directly to
each other about actual disclosed data
and so it's it's important this type of
research comes to question
you know which companies are reporting
which companies are not reporting and
can we make these conclusions about the
suggestion data findings and todd what
do you think needs to be done or
improved for those companies that aren't
reaching their their climate goals or
targets
well i think probably as you know and
the viewers of this audience know that
there are
significant strides being made across
policy regulators
exchanges
nation states
and in the companies themselves across
those regions
what we have been trying to help
facilitate through the design and build
a vsg book as a technology platform
is direct disclosure on these
climate scope data for example or more
broadly esg data
it's important for companies to
communicate and disclose at scale
you know again
there are leaders in the field who are
putting out this high quality data into
public markets through either formal
filings or through their websites
but what we have designed and built for
the last two and a half three years is a
technology disclosure platform to help
facilitate that disclosure across
companies not just public companies but
also privates
so again data data disclosure is
paramount as we try to
make this transition of the economy from
a brown economy to a green economy if
you will
and the companies need to be able to
have the tools at their disposal
to signal to the markets what they're
doing and
quantitatively speaking you know at the
data level okay todd thank you very much
for your input today
thank you
well let's get some of the day's other
climate news now because baghdad has
been hit by a severe sandstorm stopping
flights from the airport and sending
dozens of people to hospital with
breathing problems now shops were closed
on the streets of iraq's capital as the
storm restricted visibility and anyone
venturing out onto the streets wore a
mask drought and declining rainfall
means sand storms are becoming more
frequent in iraq with several hitting
the country over the past month
a global alliance has been launched in
support of vanuatu's bid for the
international courts of justice to
consider the human rights impact of
climate change more than 1 500
organizations from 130 countries are
backing the pacific island nation's
action vanuatu itself at high risk of
climate impact says the icj needs to
protect vulnerable communities and the
rights of residents who are at the front
lines of climate change
millions of birds have disappeared over
the past two decades due to the
destruction of their habitats climate
change and pollution a review led by
manchester metropolitan university found
that of around 11 000 bird species
populations of half of them are falling
and one exception is among water birds
where populations living in wetlands in
europe and north america have risen 13
since 1917.
and flying insects have declined nearly
60 in less than 20 years in the uk the
kent wildlife trust and bug life use the
windscreen phenomenon to find out what's
happening to bugs in the uk the survey
used data from drivers who reported the
quantity of squashed insects they found
on their car number plates after driving
a certain
distance
well the climate crisis is ever more
urgent and the people coming up with the
solutions are getting younger it seems
in the annual raspberry pi competition
children as young as eight were asked to
design tech that helped save the planet
[Music]
hi we are the raspberry pioneers we are
team raspberry reef hi we are sunflower
solar our invention is to help
electricity from solar panels get around
the world by
creating the time zone so the solar
panel moves in the direction of the sun
and we've created a domesticated house
plant where people were gardening during
provide and lock down however now that
everything's come back to normal there's
a lot less and a lot less produce is
being made and the prices are inflating
at really high rates and therefore we
decided that if we create something to
help people grow their own produce we
can control this let's be inspired by
their willingness to experiment their
willingness to have a go their
willingness to have impact we've
invented a capsule which helps protect
and sustain coral reefs we're looking
for different environmental changes
which can damage coral reefs and the
main two are ph and temperature so we've
invented the capture which can measure
temperature and when it detects the
temperature has changed by too much for
too long it will release calcium
carbonate solution which is what corals
use to grow their exoskeletons who are
we
to question
what is clearly the most important issue
on the agenda of children today we need
to give them the space to innovate and
the space to have impact
well do stay with us coming up
i'll be joined by founder of terror
praxis kirsty gogan and chidi oti
obihara who's a senior finance
researcher at project draw down we'll be
discussing what shells should be doing
with those bumper profits and which
countries are leading the way in
corporate climate action
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news so let's get
straight into some of those climate
issues with founder of terror practice
kirsty gogan and chidi oti obihara a
senior finance researcher at project
draw down thank you so much for joining
us today
pleasure to be here thanks for having us
let's kick off with the the first big
story so the announcement of bumper
profits from shell this morning so
similar to bp earlier in the week is
increasing the pressure on the
government to implement a win for tax um
kirsty i'll start with you
what do you think
shell should do with their profits where
should they put that money
well i think you know the government
does have um a real need to address the
very near-term crisis that people are
experiencing with the cost of living and
particularly the you know incredible
increases we've seen in energy costs
that are pushing millions of people into
energy poverty in this country right now
and you know the opportunity for a
windfall tax on the recent profits the
record-breaking profits
does seem like a sensible
option that should be considered now at
the same time the energy companies do
also have you know a real need to invest
in the sort of longer term
crisis that's also unfolding uh which is
the climate crisis and the need to
invest in the clean energy transition so
there may be a way to combine these two
um these two requirements by
earmarking some of that uh windfall
uh for investment in clean energy and
energy efficiency that can help protect
consumers in future from the kind of
price volatility and crunch that we've
seen recently as well as supporting um
the the most vulnerable people in the
near term as well
chidi there will be lots of people
watching tonight and they'll be thinking
you know what they could do with a bit
of help with their energy bills do you
think a windfall tax would help those
people
well there's a pallet of things that
government can do um government can
either uh impose a windfall tax on
companies like shell
which uh the italians this morning for
example they impose 25 win full tax on
their energy companies uh the french
also uh did something similar they
placed a cap on edf uh worth about 8.5
billion euros
so you can either impose windfall tax on
the companies or you can cap the amount
of money they charge consumers either
way you you buffer consumers from this
really large exogenous shock um i think
policymakers have to make a choice by
doing one or the other but not doing
either is is going to be really
challenging uh we spoke on this program
a couple months ago when i talked about
how it's really obvious that there are
new routes out of energy poverty that
don't involve renewables and here we are
you know months later uh living that
reality because while we listen to large
corporate titans like shell
talk about you know declaring nine
billion dollars in in in profits and
talk about how they intend to put uh
something like five or six percent of
that uh uh towards transition we know
that bp for example is putting 12
of that towards transition we know that
total energy is putting 20
of its free cash flows towards
transition we need to get to the point
we start to have these detailed
conversations
about what proportion of profits that
these companies use to actually affect
transition
and we need to get to the point where we
say
it's time to stop investing
in new fossil fuel projects and only
exclusively invest in new renewable
projects because the cost dynamics make
it really clear this is the right
business decision to make there's a
really interesting uh report which i'm
sure that kirsty knows about that lazard
wrote a couple years ago and they've
updated last year it's the levelized
cost electricity report and in it um you
know uh large-scale solar energy
is you know possibly the cheapest energy
that's available right now it's sort of
20 something dollars for the
whereas what shell is doing what other
entities are doing are you so much more
expensive it's actually both wasteful
and painful to keep investing in new uh
fossil fuels what shell will be saying
kirsty is that you know they're willing
to invest we said it early didn't we
that they're willing to invest from 20
to 25 billion in the uk in the next
decade in low carbon energy
ministers will of course have to keep a
close eye on whether that happens they
say it's a good deal what do you say
i think it's you know it's really
important that these companies are
investing but i do think that there is
an important role for government and you
know
organizations like ours in defining you
know where the investment should be
going we've put a lot of emphasis on
investment in the electricity sector
decarbonizing the electricity sector and
wind and solar as chidi said have been
very successful in becoming quite cheap
and you know being delivered at scale
which is fantastic
but the reality is is that the
electricity sector is only 20 of our
energy use and actually you know heating
industry
heavy transport especially uh aviation
shipping um you know steel cement
concrete you know all of all of the
sectors that keep our economy moving
are really a lot of those are really
hard to electrify
and a lot of those depend on oil and gas
and so we are going to need to diversify
our strategies diversify our investments
and we need some policy direction
government can help do that
taking from the lessons
in the renewables sector to support
investment in
clean substitute fuels production for
example and nuclear energy would be very
well suited to support that carbon
capture and storage and other
technologies in addition to wind and
solar that can help us decarbonize other
parts of the economy so yes it's the
amount that we're investing but it's
also where that money is being invested
and you know we have great examples of
um of how government policy can support
innovation that um eventually does drive
down costs and enables really
competitive and very high quality
technologies and coming to market one
example of course is famously you know
elon musk enjoyed some real investment
from the us government that led
ultimately
to you know the world's most successful
electric car being commercialized
so much more we could we could talk
about this but i want to pause this
subject very briefly because the other
story we're talking about today um is
all about corporate action on climate
and um it's doesn't really set our
hearts on fire i know but it is
important and uh while we've heard a lot
about pressure on energy companies the
data we looked at earlier shows that
businesses across the world need to do
more to improve their climate targets
now uh chidi i'll i'll start with you
first of all are you surprised by that
that fact that we heard that sort of
sub-sahara is leading the way and latin
america is leading the way in corporate
climate action
no no no i'm not um and one of the
reasons why i'm not surprised is that
you know to speak even more into uh what
kirstie was just saying she's absolutely
right
industry and innovation have to play a
big part
as we move forward and there's a good
charm for many african countries and
south american countries and global
south in general to leapfrog the the
dirty industrial past that the west
unfortunately had to you know
hang its wagon onto you so we got to
this point so because of that i think
you have more leeway as you focus on new
investments to to build out uh a
renewable energy future in in places
that are growing very quickly and who
can do so at a lower carbon intensity
and that's the crucial point uh because
you know as kirsty said if you have a
firm or industry or private financiers
who focus on the energy intensity of new
businesses who focus on carbon
sequestering businesses as a priority
you can make a difference i think
perhaps even faster than governments can
we saw it for example when cop went
slightly billy up a few months ago uh
and and mark carney along with
financiers got together and formed g
fans who made promises that appeared to
be far more ambitious than the
governments had appeared to be able to
do so within the figures that you've
showed us for africa and latin america i
see
i see solid business progress and i see
the opportunity
to leapfrog dirty energy systems and
build a new i think that's a very much
so much potential and positivity out
there kirsty how do you think
companies should be held accountable
then for their climate targets
well that's one of the really important
uh functions of reports like this is
that it really does provide
accountability and when you look at um
you know the scale of carbon emissions
reduction needed within a very short
time period 28 years now to 2050 a
friend of mine likes to describe it as
uh you know he says i like to ski but
that's a
such a steep slope i wouldn't want to
steed out ski down that
slope of carbon reduction that's
required so it's very dramatic the the
scale of emissions reduction that's
needed and therefore we do need to keep
very regular track we need to have that
kind of accountability and importantly
we also need to identify the areas where
we are making progress and why and also
the areas in which we're not
and particularly in the areas in which
we're really not making progress and
again i would i would point to you know
the 80 of energy use outside of the
power sector as being an area that needs
a lot of attention we need to develop
strategies for decarbonizing um
those sectors of the economy um that
have tended to be neglected because we
don't have very good answers and as
these developing countries particularly
begin to industrialize and grow their
economies it's very likely that their
energy consumption will increase in
those sectors as they want to build
hundreds of new schools and hundreds of
new hospitals and build out their
industrial capability um that they may
quickly find that themselves in a very
similar
kind of energy intensive carbon
intensive economy that we also
find ourselves in the existing developed
country thank you kirsty i'm so sorry we
have run out of time it was such a
pleasure to talk to you and hopefully
we'll have you back on the show very
very soon um well that's all from us
thank you very much for watching we will
see you next time bye
[Music]